subitement comme ça en une seconde et là
il se lève fait le tour de son immense
bureau il vient s'asseoir à côté de moi
il met ses mains sur sur mes épaules
comme ça et ils m'embrassent et il m'a
basculé avec ses mains sur la moquette
et il a il a enlevé mon pantalon il
avait enlevé son pantalon et et il m'a
violée
puis au bout d'une minute s'est rhabillé
mais sur un billet et il m'a dit mais un
bon soir à demain je me suis sentie
sauver honte je me suis senti un peu
sale jeu sallaumines
alors ce témoignage arrive dans un
contexte particulier ou ppda a attaqué
les 16 femmes qui l'avait accusé de
harcèlement et de viol pour diffamation
oui il avait porté plainte une première
fois sans suite et là il a porté plainte
avec constitution de partie civile un
rapport de 43 pages très détaillée en
les accusant de mentir et ses dix ans je
n'ai jamais fait les faits qui me sont
reprochés et il a publié des extraits
ses avocats ont sorti des extraits qui
avait dans le reportage hier à chaque
fois de lettres ou message envoyé par
les victimes présumées après comme pour
se dédouaner
dans l'émission a cartonné évidemment
parce que si on va pas se mentir c'est
un sujet qui est putassier l'enquète été
très bien faite sur la forme mais moi je
les trouvais extrêmement maladroite
pourquoi parce qu'elle sous-entend que
ppda était protégé pendant 30 ans
d'ailleurs ça s'appelle la chute d'un
intouchable ou qu'il était intouchable
alors ça sous entend aussi que tf1 était
au courant de ses agissements et n'a
rien dit et je trouve qui mélange un peu
tout parce qu'effectivement ils ont
mélangé les scandales notamment de
l'interview bidonné laon la ppd a été
protégée pourquoi parce qu'on va pas se
mentir il faisait également beaucoup
d'audience mais rien ne prouve que ppda
a été protégée pour ses scandales
sexuels tf1 n'était pas au courant c'est
la ligne de défense de tf1 est
évidemment que si tf1 était au courant
d'accusations de viol ça je voudrais ça
je vous dis ma tâche est avéré avec
chavanel viol non mais c'est pas un
dragueur oui mais pas pas sur les
accusations de viol on ne peut pas
laisser dire ça c'est trop maladroit il
ya eu des alertes quand il ya autre
chose qui me gêne c'est le réalisateur
de ce documentaire donc s'appelle romain
verley qui est un ancien collaborateur
de ppda donc dans son jt d'ailleurs il
commence le dock avec un lancement de
ppda qui cite le réalisateur au delà du
fait que je trouve c'est une sorte de
trahison évidemment il faut traiter
cette affaire mais je pense qu'ils ont
eu d'autres personnes pour réaliser ce
documentaire parce qu'il a eu accès à
des documents et des informations
confidentielles je trouve que c'est
profondément malhonnête de sa part cet
homme a dit sur sud radio et quelques
jours a tf1 on était tous au courant que
ppda et est un dragueur lourd pourquoi
il n'a rien dit à l'époque alors moi ça
me choque et je trouve que c'était un
reportage un peu malhonnête et banale
témoignage de muriel chez miel vous
parlez d'un nom du réalisateur on va
regarder brûler
d'abord je voudrais préciser que les des
proches aidants de plainte de monsieur
patrick poivre d'avor ont été classées
sans suite le procureur a pas souhaité
poursuivre très très bien cette nouvelle
plainte c'est très bien parce que ça va
nous permettre peut-être enfin d'avoir
un procès ça va nous permettre de
pouvoir nous exprimer publiquement sa va
pouvoir nous permettre de faire
témoigner d'autres personnes et
peut-être d'autres victimes donc c'est
même assez inespéré nous on se réjouit
de cette crainte que vous m'apprenez ce
soir d'ailleurs mais voilà je me réjouis
et je pense qu'on va tous se réjouir et
cette accusation envers cette femme je
peux vous dire que les sept femmes qui
sont mises en accusations telles que
vous venez de me le dire dans cette
lente
maintien dron lors des positions
d'agression sexuelle et de viol bon la
protection dont on a parlé hier avec
avec cyril c'est vrai qu'on se demande
comment ça peut devenir pendant toutes
ces années et puis au pire on va parler
après bien pire que ça il ya des
scandales sur les interviews il ya des
affaires botton veut que les voilà il ya
beaucoup de choses ou le dossier bda blu
banon est assez c est assez lourd voilà
17 plaintes maintenant avec celles qui
sont jaunes depuis le reportage dont 8
pour viol et faut noter que les victimes
ne sont pas forcément atterré mécontente
de la plainte de ppda parce que si ça va
robot il y aura procès là on est sûr que
cette fois il y aura procès alors que
dans les plaintes on sait pas encore
excellent au bout alors voila si ça va
au bout dans ces cas là il y aura procès
et déballage elles ont déjà des airs
attention dans ces cas-là on viendra
tout et on dira ce qui s'est passé donc
c'est peut-être une stratégie qui paraît
habile mais qui pourrait être pour lui
contre-productive on va regarder un
autre témoignage celle de chevet de
muriel muriel sur la même dans la
première déposition la première
inscription il a dit c'est public et
accessible
il a dit je lui aurais proposé je lui ai
proposé de faire l'amour mais pas de
cette façon là cette façon là étant la
façon que j'ai décrite précédemment
c'est à dire se retrouver en cas de sont
donc il m'a proposé
effectivement du dit il de faire l'amour
dans sa première déposition aujourd'hui
il dit je suis une femme éconduite alors
moi j'ai envie de lui dire monsieur
poivre d'arvor je suis une femme
éconduite où vous m'avez proposé de
faire l'amour vous ressentez quoi
justement quand vous voyez ces propos
qui vous visent un goûter c'est
consternant
voilà c'est assez hallucinant quand même
de voir tous ces témoignages un temps
classée sans suite ça revient lui il
attaque pour diffamation c'est certain
va jamais s'arrêter oui bien sûr non
mais en plus c'est très bien de donner
la parole à ces femmes ya des
témoignages qui sont édifiants après
encore une fois dans le traitement
journalistique je trouve qu'il y avait
des témoignages qui n'avaient pas
forcément leur place dans l'émission on
parle quand même d'accusations de viols
de harcèlement sexuel il ya eu le
témoignage de frédérique lantieri qui
est à l'ancienne présentatrice de faites
entrer l'accusé qui était sur france 2
où elle raconte en fait elle s'est fait
draguer un peu lourdement et qu'un jour
il s'est vengé en la voyant dans un
couloir en disant mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait là celle-là je ne pense qu'on veut
pas mettre ça sur le même plan que des
accusations de viol qui sont extrêmement
graves et c'était un reportage qui était
complètement à charge il faut le dire
l'eau est d'accord enfin la cote quand
il ya seize plaintes guillaume
une plainte récente pour viol mais c'est
compliqué pas moi je veux bien qu'on le
dit pas il est présumé innocent d'accord
mais quand même de tomber dans
l'accumulation de témoignages de mettre
tout sur le même plan évidemment qu'il
faut donner la parole à ces femmes et ce
qu'elle raconte encore une fois est très
grave mais on ne peut pas tout mélanger
la frontière la question ppda c'est de
savoir s'il était un dragueur lourd
seriez jusqu'à preuve du contraire légal
où c'était un délinquant sexuel en
agresseur un violeur et on ne peut pas
tout mélanger et je pense que
journalistique mans ils ont un peu par
mélangera guerlot c'est du harcèlement
guillaumin c est coupé par la loi à
partir du moment où il a dragué et
qu'elle n'a pas voulu de lui et que ans
au travail il la voix est entre
guillemets il la sort puisqu'il dit
qu'est ce qu'elle fout là celle-là c'est
ma passion oui mais quand à eux dans un
couloir bien même c'est grave parce que
t'as pas voulu coucher avec un make up
n'a pas voulu sortir avec lui que le mec
il a droit te croiser dans un couloir et
à dire 4k foule à celle là comme si tu
étais une grosse merde bien sûr c'est
très agressif et c'est très pesant pour
une femme et ça ça doit pas exister
parce que c'est du harcèlement
un rire je tenais juste par rapport à
tous les tableaux nager on est d'accord
que tout ce qu'on dit expliquer ces
femmes il ya comme une espèce de de tout
de même le même label le même cérémonie
la menace de procéder voilà c'est ça
c'est un peu surtout exactement on a un
témoignage à de estelle youssoufa requis
et qui n'ont pas regardé cet ami a
rencontré les médias au travail elle lui
dit clairement et à plusieurs reprises
de nombreuses fois niet il continue à la
harcelait mais des dizaines et des
dizaines de messages enflammés to study
tandis que les uns que les autres ça va
jusqu'au point où ils déboulent lui ppda
tous lors du 20 heures qu'il est en bas
de chez elle à la porte en train de
hurler à l'amour et comme on dire elle
doit demander à son mari de descendre
pour le chasser parce que ppda a exigé
de vouloir monter sans lé là et elle a
dû changer de numéro
parce que il ne
m'entendais pas sont reçus
et on est sûr de la répétition lassés du
harcèlement et c'est vrai que quand les
policiers l'avaient interrogé il avait
d'ailleurs évoqué le terme de êtes-vous
un prédateur sexuel il lui avait demandé
ce qu'il a totalement démenti et pour
vous répondre je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vous parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un système ppda
c'est un système répétitif avec des
protections des affaires étouffées on en
a parlé jeudi on a retrouvé des faits de
2009 notamment des affaires qui ont été
établis avec des enquêtes et puis y'a
pas eu de jugement ya rien eu et ces
femmes aujourd'hui elle témoigne parce
que si elle ne témoigne pas dans des
reportages comme ça leurs paroles ne
serait pas sorti alors juste parce qu'on
va revoir pour voir un autre témoignage
ayew tf1 il ya eu radio classique aussi
celle qui fait tous les grands espaces
apparemment il ya des témoignages qui
sont plutôt compliqué regardez
béatrice moheddine a travaillé à ses
côtés pendant quatre ans
et dans leur studio elle dit avoir vu le
ballet des jeunes femmes recommencer ça
arrivait assez souvent je dirais une à
deux fois par semaine et à chaque fois
ce qui était frappant c'est que c'était
donc
tout des jeunes femmes très apprêtée
très joli il les faisait
s'asseoir en studio sur un tabouret
au bout du studio pendant pendant une
heure et de 13 ans il ne l'est présentée
par le disait pas vain béatrice qui
présentent les infos et mademoiselle et
je n'ai jamais osé
moi m'adresse à elle je m'en veux de ça
j'aurais dû parce que elle était souvent
très intimidés ils s'étaient
dépersonnaliser son nom pas de prénom
on retrouve ces fameuses routine c'est
la même chose à chaque fois ce qui est
vrai pour rebondir ce que dit sur ce que
dit gilles c'est qu'à travers ce
reportage ce désir se dessine une sorte
de mode opératoire ce groupe et à un
violeur en série non mais non seulement
ils jouissaient de sa notoriété mais en
plus il invitait souvent sur son lieu de
travail des femmes ou des jeunes femmes
il jouissait de sa notoriété de ceux de
son statut de présentateur star il
faisait 10 millions de téléspectateurs
il y avait effectivement ce rituel
d'inviter des femmes sur son lieu de
travail et d'avoir des comportements qui
était qui aurait été inacceptable alors
on a l'image de marc également 24 ans un
témoignage qui est glaçant regardez
donc là on m'amène dans son bureau donc
j'étais face à patrick poivre d'arvor
mon rédacteur en chef et d'un bandeau
patrick poivre d'arvor me dit je sais
plus bravo pour tout sujet
j'ai une première ce soir je t'invite la
lumière s'éteint le spectacle commence
et c'est devenu plus compliqué parce que
où il ya eu des gestes déplacés
une main mise sur la cuisse à une main
qui n'a pas être là à l'entracte en fait
il me dit on reste pas assez bon je me
suis montrée donc il me dit on va dîner
il m'a serré contre lui
il est ici
de m'embrasser quoi est-ce qu'à l'époque
vous en avez parlé aux rédacteurs en
chef ou directeur de la rédaction nous
parce que ces faits pda par contre alors
ça c'est un fait une réponse qui revient
très fréquemment tahir m une directrice
en scène et actrice de l'ipg de
journalisme le cardigan montpon pendant
dix ans les gens disent de tf1 ont dit
qu'il fallait surtout pas envoyer des
stagiaires la basse et la corde quand
vous dites que personne n'avait osé moi
c'est une omerta absolue regardez chaque
fois il me conseillait depuis l'année
83,84 de ne jamais envoyer deux filles
là où ppda pouvait être pendant dix ans
je n'ai jamais envoyé une fille en stage
atf qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
c'est une accusation grave c'est une
accusation g et mais l'ensemble des
journalistes de la rédaction à l'époque
le disait disait quoi ils disaient qu'il
fallait pas rester dans la rédaction de
tf1 en fin de journée est ce le dernier
la dernière à partir parce que sinon
ppda ce risque est se jeter sur vous
pourquoi à l'époque vous n'avez rien dit
mais à l'époque je mangeais dit ce que
j'avais à dire à mes étudiantes
impossible d'aller le dire à tf1 en
prenons mais tf1 c'était leur affaire de
régler un problème d'un salarié mais
pourquoi alors on en a jamais parlé de
ça
il y avait cette omerta siakago gilles
galléan capture été faite la drh étaient
au courant voilà c'était un secret de
polichinelle et je passe toutes les
histoires la rivalité entre autres
dirigeants de tf1 et ppda il faut
partager la même femme à moi et c'est
tout le monde était au courant je peux
partager un peu non est-ce que c'est
pourquoi pour pourquoi cette omerta est
ce que parce que ppda faisait des scores
énorme et on se disait le business
d'abord il faut rien dire est ce que
pourquoi les gens donc pourquoi pas
pourquoi ça c'est ce qu'elle gill a
soulevé hier en fait il semblerait que
pendant des dizaines d'années pendant
vingt ans il ya eu une protection alors
à quel niveau est ce que c'est une
protection et celle des médias c'est une
protection déjà des médias c'est sûr et
sur ce que serait ce que ça va plus loin
que cette protection judiciaire
politique au pays mais on peut tout
imaginer c'est très possible mais ce qui
est dingue c'est que malgré tous ces
témoignages et toutes ses plaintes ppda
à afficher une de défense le tout c'est
de la calomnie et c'est la réponse de
pda on l'a regardé
pour sa défense patrick poivre d'arvor a
rejoint des lettres manuscrites qu'il
attribue à quatre de ses accusatrices à
lui aurait écrit peu de temps après les
viols ou agressions qu'elle dénonce
selon ppda ces courriers qu'il présente
comme affectueux conforterait sa version
des faits en voici quelques extraits
anonymisées pas un jour sans une pensée
pour vous quand nous reverrons nous en
attendant ce moment je vous embrasse
affectueusement merci de m'avoir écouté
par les embrasser j'ai déjà envie de
vous revoir et j'ai déjà peur de cette
envie dans quel contexte ces lettres ont
elles été envoyées ces femmes ont-elles
écrit librement ou était-elle sous
emprise
c'est ça le puissance l'encré c'est ça
c'est ça l'idée c'était la star
d'ailleurs c'est dit dans le reportage
était la star intouchable faut juste
préciser quand même que pour le moment
il ya une enquête donc de la pj de
nanterre qui veut globalisé serre qui
vont reprendre toutes les affaires ils
veulent élargir comme ils disent voilà
il ya non seulement présomption
d'innocence faut le rappeler quand même
si les rangs talent mais il n'y a pas de
charge il ya une enquête et après on
verra où ses talents mais juste j'ai
parce qu'on a travaillé ensemble on dit
présomption d'innocence les enquêtes de
police menée sur les huit cas dont on a
parlé hier il marque et il est marqué
dans les dossiers oui que c'est fondé il
ya eu des faits commis faits établis
avérés et pas de suite c'est ce qui
interroge c'est pour ça qu'on a à parler
de de protection d'éventuelles affaires
étouffées une agression sexuelle un viol
en 2009 notamment violent 2009 rappelant
que ce ne seraient pas prescrits ses 20
ans pour viol donc à voir c'est à dire
que s'il ya un procès et que ya
condamnation ces dix 10 ans 15 ans de
prison oui si jamais c'est établi s'est
jamais s'établissent à peut être quinze
ans mais on n'en est pas encore là pour
le moment il ya juste une enquête qui va
tenter de voir parmi tous ces faits s'il
peut y avoir des poursuites en justice
mais il ya un collectif quand même qui
s'est créé et que si a trahi et dominés
13 et amélia 16 femmes qui sont prêtes à
témoigner oui d'une seule voix oui
d'accord quand même je sais maintenant
après cette dispute mater gars aiment
beaucoup il aura quand même fallu andres
15 ans et le retrait de ppda à tf1 pour
que son système le système des pda soit
démantelée que les témoignages
concordants sortent au grand jour je ne
suis pas si convaincu qu'ils puissent se
relever de cette affaire voilà il est
tombé déjà
s'est excusé moi ce qui est grave il
n'est pas tombé il a fini sa carrière
donc en vrai c'est aujourd'hui il a plus
rien à perdre le gard ça y est il est
âgé il a pas maintenant il ya mais quel
honneur arrête se dirait un moment donné
il il a été tranquille pendant 15 ans 17
ans tu es une star on le voyait tous
dans la rue on le voyait c'était une
icône et à la fin de sa carrière quand
elles font ils en ont plus besoin il ya
tout qui explosent comme ça mais en tout
cas le pari a tu sais pas qu'est ce qui
est injuste pour les victimes c'est que
en vrai bas effectivement il n'a plus
rien à perdre je suis désolé moi je le
dis ouvertement il n'a plus rien à
perdre sa mère sally la fed a gagné la
partie l'année ses années de gloire ça
va tu voyais plus rien à perdre s'il
passe la corde elle en prison
ok mais il a quel âge excusez moi mais
les 40 70 à 100 combien d'années
procédure c'est la peau appel machin tu
connais la justice en france est long
c'est très long calmes et les assises
une fois que ces inscrits en 3 4 ans et
boucler un hoquet 1080 en 85 ans et 75
ans une agence à rien pour les mêmes
cadeaux pour les victimes d'importants
sujets médiatiques pour le coup là la
presse adore faire des papiers soumises
aurait du mal de retard l'escouade
horaire